i also want to ask about the black lives
matter
movement db leslie ann at one point said
that you were hurting with everything
that was going on
and i just kind of wanted to ask you and
give you an opportunity
to to talk about the importance of the
movement um
and how you're you're feeling the
movement is
uh extremely important and um you know
we all have to
push this change that that we really
want to see um yeah
it it you know listen um i think anybody
that's
that's
black this has been a really uh
challenging time
you know and and i i think it's what
what i think what we're learning
is that there's a there's a whole lot
that white people really didn't
understand
um didn't know and perhaps
some of that was because they they
didn't take um
they didn't take the initiative to
really know
to really find out and so what i'm
saying now to people is
listen if you see uh injustice anywhere
you have a responsibility to write that
injustice
you have a moral obligation those of us
um who are privileged enough to do what
we do
um i think we especially have have a bit
more responsibility to uh
reach out and to and to use our
platforms for good
um i'm someone that um
when all this stuff started happening i
don't think i realized
it's crazy to start talking about these
stories because i think for so many
african americans we
compartmentalize so much so much of our
lives
and so i think for most people they see
us um
they see someone who's a professional
and they seem to be good at their job
uh doing well and they don't think
they they couldn't possibly imagine that
that uh what what some of us have gone
through just to get to the same
positions
that our white allies are in for me
george floyd
uh you know i like to believe i'm a
i'm a somewhat intelligent individual
you know uh
and you know i could tell you all about
ptsd
but i don't think i ever realized
that i suffered from it until the george
void thing started happening i wasn't
able to get out of bed for three days
that's unlike me
um and it it just brought up a whole lot
of stuff
that i had i guess
dismissed in my childhood things that
had happened to me
constantly and consistently with the
with the excuse my language
police um and
it trying to overcome that
um every day has been tough and
i think it's something that that that
most of us have learned to
like i said compartmentalized and when
the george floyd thing happened
it it it wasn't anything that that none
of us weren't used to seeing but there
was something about
this particular incident that just
just broke the back of
i think this country
and i don't think that we can go back
and so
like i said again i think that all of us
have a moral responsibility
to use these platforms for good to
educate people to to uh
to with facts uh and with the truth
something that we're not getting right
now from our federal government
um so it falls upon us
the citizens and those of us that have
privileged positions to be honest
and to help in whatever ways we can
to change this system from inside